trois ans déjà et des larmes qui n'en
finissent pas la disparition de clarissa
jean philippe sol au 18 janvier tombés
sous les balles dames et 10 colis bali
est encore dans les mémoires
au pied de la statue sculptée à son
effigie sa mère a du mal à contenir sa
peine je pense qu'elle est toujours là
la fille n'est pas morte avec moi sur
cette petite place qui désormais porte
son nom un hommage très solennel lui ai
rendu par le premier magistrat de la
ville
le sous-préfet une vingtaine de
personnes présentes dans une atmosphère
des temps ces motions venu ici la tante
de la petite voix là on en a suivi
l'événement donc on est là aujourd'hui
ça sent beaucoup de peine il faut faire
avec même avis continuer carissa moore
porte dans l'histoire de face ces deux
traits samaritaine chéri la couleur est
arrivé trois ans vous étiez a pas une
douleur ravive et chaque année par cet
instant de recueillement mais nécessaire
selon le maire de sète marie pour que
clarissa ne tombe pas dans les partis
sur les balles de ce terroriste donc je
crois que je lui dois beaucoup
la ville de cette maille lui doit
beaucoup la nation française lui dois
beaucoup nous lui devons beaucoup et il
était tout à fait normal où il serait
plutôt impensable que nous ne soyons pas
là ce matin pour commémorer en tout cas
sa mémoire pour être à côté de sa
famille et puis pour voir comment les
rayons notre chacun y va de son
initiative afin d'illustrer une forme de
reconnaissance
le représentant de l'association franco
italienne des justes de france promet la
présence de clarissa au jardin des
justes dans plusieurs villes de france
un hommage a été rendu à la police hier
de montrouge mais dans son île natale
ce moment de recueillement aurait un
caractère plus familial